curry hachimura with the rebound  he's got 11. he's got a double-double  tonight  oh my goodness  and the diving tackle by the security  with 340 to go here in the third the  redskins better look into hiring that  man right there  what a tackle there by the security well  and look how far the guy had to run you  know there's a limited  viewing and they've taken out all the  end zone seats and quickly he  is off the floor and great job by the  security in washington  well we've seen some ugly incidents the  last few  playoff games and i applaud that  we don't know what that fan did but he  did something  to get tackled like that  beautiful  so the sixers had won the first three  games of this series by  7.25 and 29 points  they have